que quand on est intermittent du
spectacle il faut faire un nombre
d'heures pour pouvoir prétendre à
l'allocation chômage sauf que moi j'ai
pas assez bossé les dernières d'accord
donc on n'a fait que troisième sur sur
ses buts d'ailleurs trois confrères et
pascal au bout du monde c'était en
mongolie 5 il n'a pas droit au rsa pour
les basques eux donc je peux pas toucher
vers ça et j'ai passé deux d'or donc
j'essaie de somme l'un de nos locations
mais c'est une occasion supplémentaire
sur un salaire tu peux toucher à
l'extérieur moi j'ai la chance je fais
mon métier à la télé je me sens pas de
la télé pour faire mon métier donc je
travaille à côté
moi je suis en mairie je m'occupe des
jeunes je suis et coach sportif
préparateur physique pour la police
municipale d'une part et pour les jeunes
qui arrivent à s'en sortir ou pas oui ça
va un jour du sabbat a enfin franchement
je veux faire un truc je sais pas si
j'ai le droit mais je me suis dit
puisque je suis ici je vais oser germes
d'un contrat de travail que j'ai déjà
paraphé donc il vous concerne ça sert il
a donc eu pour que je puisse délivrer
contraire regardez ya pas d'argent noter
donc que le ressac optique numéro 5 ha
merde il est là et où tu as vu ce que ça
va je passe passe plat
[Applaudissements]
les calculs j'enlève le pass pass ne le
savent pas je perds de losail le défaut
aux besoins parce que tu dis mais pour
toi rouet pour l'équipe c'est peut-être
une idée pour toi pour l'équipe et je
rigole